so in this video I will be talking about
biogenesis of neurotransmitters so all
the neurotransmitters are very important
in our body in order to conduction of
our nerve impulse so biogenesis of
neurotransmitters are also very
important in order to have normal
functionality and optimum functionality
of our neurons now in this video we
would focus on some of these
neurotransmitters and most of these
neurotransmitters are actually formed
from the amino acids such as
phenylalanine or other aromatic amino
acids and glutamate which is a acidic
amino acid or known as glutamic acid is
directly used as a neurotransmitter in
most of the verdi bit for Debrett
synapses so most of the vertebrate
vertebrate synapses are actually a
glutamatergic and there are others also
for example dopaminergic synapse
adrenergic noradrenergic or serotonergic
synapses so we would just look step by
step how these dopamine or serotonin or
epinephrine is produced from amino acids
so let's first talk about the
epinephrine biosynthesis pathway and in
this same biosynthesis pathway you would
find that dopamine and norepinephrine
are produced so this pathway starts with
phenyl annalynne so final alanine which
is our aromatic amino acid it has a
phenyl group you can see over here and
in this phenyl group would be
hydroxylated by final alanine
hydroxylase enzyme in order to form
tyrosine which is another aromatic amino
acid so the modification formed here is
a addition of hydroxyl group and again
another hydroxylation reaction
upon this tyrosine amino acid would form
something called Doba and it has two
hydroxyl groups you can see marked in
red and then your aromatic amino acid
decarboxylase actually remove this
carboxyl group and it would form a mind
this biological active and mine is known
as dopamine so it has basically two
hydroxyl group and these amino group so
this is known as dopamine and after that
dopamine hydroxylase enzyme would again
hydras hydroxyl ate dopamine into a
different location so here you can see
there is a hydroxylation reaction on the
dopamine and this hydroxylation reaction
would ultimately give rise to
norepinephrine and remember
norepinephrine and epinephrine that
means actually nor noradrenaline these
are actually important neurotransmitters
in let's say postganglionic nerve fibers
of sympathetic nervous system so from
norepinephrine epinephrine would be
produced so you can see this phenyl
ethyl or ethanolamine and methyl
transferase which actually transfers a
methyl group onto this a mind group of
epinephrine or epinephrine would
ultimately produce this epinephrine so
these epinephrine norepinephrine and
dopamine work individually as
neurotransmitters but remember all of
these are descended from phenylalanine
which is a amino acid so any disease
which corresponding to loss of
neurotransmitter may actually involved
with this pathway so let's talk about
the serotonin biosynthesis pathway so
the serotonin the raw material for
serotonin is tryptophan tryptophan is an
aromatic amino acid so it has a double
ring attached with it one
ben turmeric and another is hexameric so
first reaction is also hydroxylation
reaction that means addition of a
hydroxyl group by tryptophan hydroxylase
enzyme and it would form five dihydroxy
tryptophan or five DHT and five
dihydroxy tryptophan would be
decarboxylated by decarboxylase enzyme
and it would produce serotonin which is
a biologically active and mine you can
see it's a mine it's lived with these of
aromatic group with the hydroxylated end
it would produce serotonin so in this
video we discussed about the basic
biochemical pathways of biogenesis of
serotonin epinephrine norepinephrine and
dopamine in another video I would talk
about glutamate biosynthesis and how
glutamate is used as a neurotransmitter
and also about clear mate transporters I
hope you enjoyed this video if you liked
my video give it a quick thumbs up and
don't forget to leave your comments
below and please subscribe for these
videos thank you